the story you're reading about with
child wives where
families are exchanging their daughters
to taliban for safety and freedom is
that just conspiracy or is that really
happening right now
it's really happening it's not uh after
the u.s exited i mean when u.s exited it
aggravated the situation and it's
happening i mean uh uh
there are stories of afghan women who do
not have money uh families who do not
have money and they are selling
them to warlords who do not have
children and they are negotiating the
price of their kids
imagine what's happening
and uh this has this has this will only
grow further i mean the kind of human
tragedy that we are witnessing here
is
massive and mind you
the international media's attention
patrick has been on kabul
it has not been on the other uh
provinces all across afghanistan their
situation is worse
what's happening in kandahar which is
the so-called cultural or the
you know religious epicenter of the
taliban
they're killing innocents
they're killing
at point blank range summary executions
that are happening
where not just the erstwhile afghan army
people or the nda secret service people
but innocent government employees
somebody might have had an ego hassle or
some argument in the past with the
taliban those people innocence are being
butchered uh completely so this is the
reality of afghanistan right now and on
your
show today patrick i'll tell you and i
predict this that years from now united
states will be forced to enter
afghanistan again and it will not be to
fight the isis it will not be to fight
the taliban it will be to fight the
monsters that they created and they did
not care about the mushrooming islamist
terror organizations that will have
their base camps in afghanistan now
imagine globally the kind of islamic
terror groups that were
shadowing or perhaps underground did not
have as much mechanism because of the
changing dynamics that happened after 9
11 the raised alarm bells the security
cooperation the anti-terrorism
cooperation that happened will
completely now die down because the kind
of embolding that will happen and
perhaps who knows the taliban and the
pakistan will use afghanistan soil to
actually
you know mushroom these militias these
terror groups on afghanistan afghanistan
soil it's been already happening it's
not that something new will happen in
helmand
uh there have been terror cramps of
jaish muhammad lashkar jangby and others
that have been running for years
together now this is again the era of
1990
uh where mullah umar
with the pakistan isi you know ran
several camps
you know very interestingly a few years
back i met some former terrorists
in kashmir in northern a part of kashmir
called kukwara we met at a cafe there
and they confessed
they were strong built
you know more than six feet height
people who have who had may you know
stayed in prison for almost two decades
and they confessed to me that you know
they were made to cross in 1990 from
kashmir to pakistan and in pakistan they
met a corner of the pakistan
who blindfolded them put them on onto a
truck hundreds of them and send them to
afghanistan and in afghanistan they
realized that you know hey we are here
in afghanistan and they were pushed into
a camp for three months which was run by
mullah umar
and all these people and mullah omar and
others with the support of the
pakistanis and others trained them and
finally they unleashed a war you know in
kashmir where innocents were killed so
this is an ongoing
uh process now of course the binary
administration says that they will see
their diplomatic ties with pakistan they
will see some kind of realignment with
pakistan but i don't see a situation
where the united states still realizes
the consequences of letting
a pass on pakistan the same happened
with trump you know
trump when he immediately came to power
the trump administration said we will go
hammer in tongues against pakistan we
will end the defense budget completely
that is allotted to them we will not
have a security or a terror corporation
until they give us uh in writing or some
kind of a proof that they will act
against terrorists and look what
happened trump fought you know over the
years became so close to pakistan
that finally uh you know zalman almighty
was appointed who anyways was hated by
the pakistanis but
uh you know they had a cooperation going
pakistan was able to con you know
convince not just the cia but the state
department as well that they are their
ally and this is not going to change any
time soon mind you and this is going to
be the epicenter of the global jihad the
global islamist terror organizations and
unfortunately uh we have yet to see
worse unfortunately in the region so if
you like this sort of short club from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]